- dangerous winter storms are
threatening millions of Americans on
both sides of the country this morning a
powerful nor'easter is getting stronger
along the East Coast it's already dumped
more than a foot of snow in parts of New
York and Pennsylvania Massachusetts
could see 75 mile-per-hour wind gusts
and devastating coastal flooding later
today the National Weather Service calls
it a life-and-death situation for people
along the shore there will be damaging
wind gusts from the Carolinas all the
way to Maine DeMarco Morgan is in
Freeport New York on the South Shore of
Long Island where the water is already
rising demarco good morning good morning
guys you said that the water is already
starting to spill over from this canal
here in Freeport where we're standing
just look at this parking lot it is
already starting to flood in this area
and we could see anywhere up to 60
mile-per-hour wind gusts before it's all
said and done and that could mean severe
flooding for this area and along the
coast
overnight heavy snowfall buried much of
western Pennsylvania and to New York
part of a major weekend storm bearing
down on nearly the entire East Coast
some cars could be seen in banks off the
side of the highway high winds have
already taken down power lines in
Michigan knocking out electricity to
tens of thousand trees also toppled into
homes as far south as Maryland but the
brunt of the storm will strike
Massachusetts flooding is the main
concern there and it could rival
all-time records storm surges up to four
feet are possible if you live in an area
that's been told to evacuate we strongly
encourage you to do so governor Charlie
Baker stressed the dangerous storm could
be stronger than the bomb cyclone that
slammed at New England and calls to
record flooding in early January he also
signed in order to activate 200 members
of the National Guard to help prepare I
can't stress this enough it's a heck of
a storm and people need to take it
seriously
again gale we're already starting to
feel the effects of this still in the
wind it's when picking up throughout the
morning and it could get more dangerous
it could become more dangerous before
again it's all said and done it'll some
things back to you right that's the word
we're hearing this morning thank you
very much DeMarco